you know you can just be
a person who speaks on tv or does an
interview and
or writes a story i mean tom tobin and
joe childs are
enemies of scientology you know the the
reporters from the tampa bay
times in fact back in the early days
of scientology in clearwater there was a
reporter for the tampa
for the then saint beat times betty
orsini
who had exposed the fact that
scientology had purchased the fort
harrison because
when that was done it was done under the
guise
of being a front group
called the united churches of florida
right
and the southern land development and
leasing corporation
and it was like she
exposed that and she became an enemy and
there was a bunch of things that were
done by scientology to try and destroy
her
career and her life get her fired from
the saint pete times
get her husband to divorce i mean it was
like a an
out and out campaign and
there are being campaigns the mayor of
clearwater at that time
gabe cazares who was also very upset
about the fact that nobody had been up
front when we first came to clearwater
uh became the target of a monumental
efforts to destroy him
he was set up in a fake hit and run
accident
at a conference in washington dc they
planted documents
in files saying that he was bigamously
married to
a woman in mexico they got
students quote students who were
young women to claim that he was having
affairs with them
and this was all documented after
the fbi raided scientology in 1977
in washington dc and los angeles and
discovered all the documents that laid
out these
plans to destroy people wow
and so it's not just you know
anybody who is uh considered to be a
nuisance to scientology
they don't just sort of lie down and
take it
they go out and actively work to destroy
that person and shut them down and
in fact that was my job as the head of
the office of special affairs
my responsibility and what i was
judged on in that job
was the number of dismissed attackers
that was what the you counted the number
of dismissed attackers and a dismissed
attacker
is another euphemistic term for someone
that's been shut the [ __ ] up
okay whether by intimidation whether by
threats whether by legal
action of suing whether by getting a
settlement
whatever it was if that person was no
longer now
speaking about what they considered to
be the abuses or problems in scientology
that counted as uh neutralized
yeah right so you were the head of this
specific operation of neutralizing
people that were outside of scientology
trying to discredit scientology
correct so going back when you first
came back to
clearwater on apollo the boat
when you first started working in
the fort harrison flag building yeah
what were you doing there
um at the time i was the telex
operator okay scientology still used
telexes
and that's because back in the 1960s
telex was the sort of
communication method of choice um
and strangely in scientology
there is this sort of thing where if l
ron hubbard said it
then it can't be changed right so
scientology continues to use telexes to
this day
even though they may not use telex
machines per se
anymore you know the clackady clackety
clack
and they transmit over uh you know fiber
optics with a
with a computer terminal they still call
them telexes
because that's what l ron hubbard said
is the method that you're supposed to
communicate
so long i i digress always danny into
all sorts of
of strange oddball facts about these
things
but i was
in charge of re sending and receiving
communications from scientology
organizations
all over the world into
clearwater okay that's what i did
and how old were you again uh by that
time i
was uh 22
22. and at that point you were also you
were already working with david
miscavige who is the leader
like you guys were david miscavige
hadn't even come into the sea or
by then oh really no at what point did
you finally meet him
um i think in 1976
well actually back up okay truth be told
i met him and his father and his
mother and his brother and his twin
sister and his younger sister
back in 1969
when i traveled to england with my
parents
to go to the home of elrond hubbard
which is saint hill manor in
east grinstead sussex
david muscavich's parents were also
there
had traveled to england to go to the
home of l ron hubbard and study
scientology
and i met dave
his sister denise his twin sister denise
his younger sister laurie and his older
sister ron
and his mother and father then
ron jr joined the sea organization like
a year before dave did and i was friends
with ron jr in the sea org
and then dave came and i think it was
1976
and he came to clearwater he was 16.
he had not finished high school and he
came to clearwater to join the sea org
and then ultimately to go work with our
ron hubbard
who had by this time moved to california
okay now what was he doing like what was
his day-to-day job
um well it's there's
there's many but when he got he got
pretty quickly he went to california and
he was
an assistant cameraman l ron hubbard at
that time
fancied himself as a movie director and
producer
and was doing movies to
uh promote scientology and to
train what's called auditors in
scientology which is scientology
counselors
right okay and he had set up this sort
of makeshift
movie studio on a property near la
quinta
in california which is just outside of
palm springs
and david miscavige was brought there
and he was the assistant cameraman
on those shoots okay there was pictures
of miscavitch
standing there with el ron hubbard
really with a
with a you know old old style
i guess it's a 35
it's probably not even a 35 millimeter
camera whatever
yeah old old style camera yeah on camera
yeah and then from there miscavitch
graduated
to um becoming
the person uh and i'll try and avoid too
much of the terminology but
a person who was charged with
sending seog members from where l ron
hubbard
was out into different organic
scientology organizations around the
world to deal with problems
his title was actually the action chief
the action
chief the action chief seems like a good
name a good title for somebody like him
i mean watching those videos of him
walking into those big those
big giant seminars he like literally
marches out to that podium
yeah he like he's like vince mcmahon
exactly his body language
vince mcmahon exactly vince mcmahon or
tony robbins or tony robbins yeah
yeah that he he has that sort of
swagger and you know he has
a very um
a very interesting sort of
public persona that he generates
and he's all you know he'll fellow
well-met
you know shaking hands
the real david moscavich is a
a total sociopath
he is a he is a a very
um he has all the traits
of a
sociopath you know i read a fascinating
book when i
first left that was recommended
to me by someone called the sociopath
next door written by a
harvard professor called martha stout
and
i read that book and i went oh my god
this is exactly
he she wrote this book about david
biscavich my god
it's like it's exactly him and
only then did i come to realize that
this is a
you know a personality disorder it's not
it's not limited to miscavitch
uh it's not something that
that is unknown in the world outside
right it but that sort of struck me
because
i believe that he he was the only person
on planet earth that could be as nuts as
he is
right you know like yeah to me nobody
else could be quite like that
nobody else could could sink into the
levels of
depravity that he sank to
so